initiated collision
[Music]
playin hero very sweet I'm not surprised
you show real potential for the king you
haven't need a mentor Virgil you just
let me know hey everybody it's Charlie
so a bunch of you've been asking for a
Black Lightning video so I wanted to do
DC TV because so much is happening next
week so we're going to start with slash
vs. Black Lightning
because Black Lightning is our latest
lightning based character in the DC TV
universe so when new powers who'd win is
a fight and most of you have probably
seen a version of him in one of the TV
shows before so I'll explain where to
find him but he's been a relatively
minor character the flash has always
been an a-list Justice League member
he's always been a huge character his
comics still sell like crazy Black
Lightning has been B list at best
he hasn't been used a whole lot because
he just hasn't been super popular and
there have been a couple of rights
issues that have prevented him from
showing up in TV shows it's one of those
weird situations where the creator of a
character owns a percentage of the
character like Bob Kane owns a
percentage of Batman so when they did
the 60s Batman TV show
he earned a small percentage of that he
owns like a small percentage of the
rights
so there been a couple versions of Black
Lightning that have showed up during
different animated series but we never
seen a live-action version and I think
the reason why he's getting a TV show
now is largely built on the success of
Luke Cage people like okay we wanted to
are serious about this african-american
that comes back to clean up his
neighborhood look like a damn
and that's kind of how the black
lightning shows being build but the cool
stuff you want to know all about his
powers so he in the flash both have
lightning based powers but their
lightning comes from very different
places the flash TV show has really
simplified the concept of the Speed
Force the way it worse they just call it
this extra dimensional energy field that
exists beyond time and space that's
where the Flash's lightning comes from
it's almost like Dark Matter lightning
so it's a little bit different from
traditional lightning that you see in
Earth's atmosphere like lightnings power
is generated from the Earth's electrical
field it's almost like a slightly
different version of Magneto's power
when Magneto's generating
electromagnetic fields he uses it to
generate shield he uses it to levitate
that's kind of the same way that black
lightnings powers work to so he can use
it to generate force fields he can use
it to levitate he has limited flight
abilities he can stop bullets
projectiles in midair but it requires a
lot of concentration and even though
they haven't really explored the limits
of his powers yet in the comics he can
do pretty much anything that you could
do with electrical field like if you
remember the episode of the flash where
flash uses his speed force lightning to
sort of wake up restart Jesse quicks
heart
Black Lightning can do that same thing
too he can use it to stimulate people's
brains really it's only limited by your
imagination but it's different types of
lightning fusing spins charge the magic
like an electric turbine but the
lightning that they manifest comes from
different places in black lightning
unlike the flash doesn't generate the
lightning from his body itself the cool
thing about the flash is that his body
has sort of become the speed force
incarnate like it's bonded with his DNA
so the TV show hasn't really done this
storyline yet but on a fundamental level
Barry Allen generates the Speed Force
himself black lightning doesn't generate
the lightning his body serves as more of
a conduit for the Earth's
electromagnetic field if you've even
watched a little bit of the flash TV
show or any of the DC TV shows they've
done livewire - there's a lot of
electricity based villains you have a
pretty good preview of what black
lightnings powers are going to look like
on screen but they'll change it a little
bit typically when they do new villains
that have similar powers they try to
differentiate them as much as possible
but were flashed to go up against black
lightning the only way black lightning
would be able to beat him is if he could
generate an electromagnetic field long
enough to disrupt the Flash's speed
force ma'am I'm gonna have to ask you to
leave the building
bestir that's fun I like to have fun too
I see you've got a lot to learn about
your power yeah it's like that they do
that that's cool
there's no way you're going to be faster
than the flash so there's only a couple
ways to stop him dead in his tracks and
one is to disrupt the electromagnetic
field that he generates using the Speed
Force black lightning can do that if
he's fast enough in the flash even
though he does serve as a conduit in a
generator for the Speed Force is still
susceptible to lightning strikes zoom
grabbing and hitting him with his own
lightning both is the best example of
that so the flash is still more powerful
but just like when Oliver Queen goes up
against the flash typically you have to
out sink him because he hasn't been
fighting for that long but each new
season the flash learns all these new
lessons gets more and more powerful and
I know it's a long-running joke but
technically based on the big twist of
the season 3 bill and on the flash he is
still the fastest man alive so what's
going on with the black lightning season
one is that the CW did officially
greenlight it so it's going to be an
actual TV show with episodes on the CW
they didn't say which night it's going
to air on and they didn't say when it's
going to premiere but that means the
Greg Berlanti has 5 TV shows on the CW
there's only so many nights during the
week in nightmare scenario they aired on
Tuesday nights because legends of
tomorrow's on Tuesday nights but it
sounds like it's going to be a 13
episode run so they can spend a little
bit more money on the special effects
it's going to feel a lot like Luke Cage
because he's this older man who's coming
back to his neighborhood to clean it up
using his abilities sort of like the
other long-running commentary on DC TV
is that Diggle needs powers will Diggle
be the Jon Stewart of the DC TV universe
will Diggle be Guardian but they did
different things with those characters
they turned the Jimmy Olsen character on
Supergirl into Guardian so Diggle is the
best version of DC TV Luke Cage right
now they haven't said too much about
what crossover with the other DC TV
shows is going to look like so I think
it'll be minimal in season 1 and then
they'll see how it goes then they'll
think about crossing it over anything
out of the pages of DC Comics that's
being produced by the CW network is fair
game to cross over but they said they've
just started thinking of ideas for the
next four night crossover for this year
so that would be a good place for Black
Lightning to show up if they're going to
cross them over what the other shows but
you guys can let me know like what do
you think
about the black lightning characters
there been a couple different versions
of him you can find him on the Young
Justice series he serves as a mentor to
static shock I know a lot of you're like
why didn't they make a static shock
series well I think that's because they
wanted to do a Luke Cage type show in
static shock as a young kid and they've
been trying to get a static shock TV
show off the ground for a long time they
haven't said much about Young Justice
season three in terms of the roster how
that's going to change but static shock
could always show up during that but let
me know which DC TV videos you guys want
me to do the next couple days they'll be
some new flash this weekend for finale
stuff but as we learn more about the new
series that are coming especially the
Titans TV show in Young Justice season 3
I'll do new videos for that will
probably end up happening because
there's so many DC TV shows dropping and
there's a lot of Marvel TV coming is
I'll have to find a way to do videos for
multiple shows in single videos I
haven't quite figured out how that's
going to work but we have about a year
before a lot of these shows drop so it's
not that big a deal right now but next
video is going to be new defenders
they've been dropping a bunch of promos
so I'll do a video for that a little
while congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Justin tube HD please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details while you wait for everything to
drop you can click here for brand new
flash footage and you can click here to
learn all about the Deadpool TV series
and New Mutants thank you so much for
watching let's have five I'll see you
guys tonight